do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video I'm actually recording this
video in advance as of right now the
first episode has not aired but by the
time you see this video the first
episode will have just ended the reason
why I'm making this video now is because
I wanted to be able to upload something
as soon as the first episode was over
that way all of you can leave me some of
your initial thoughts on that episode by
the time you're watching this video I
will be working on my breakdown video
which I will release ASAP what I want to
talk about in this video is which member
from how stark do you think will die
first this is the first time we have
seen all the Starks together since the
very first season of this incredible
show I know I've been waiting for this
day for a very long time but
unfortunately this may not last very
long as we all know the night king is
heading their way and we already know
Winterfell will be the setting for one
of the greatest battles in cinematic
history based on everything we have seen
so far you can almost guarantee we will
lose some of our beloved characters in
that battle not only does it look like
the Starks entire Castle will catch on
fire but it also looks like the night
Kings army makes it over the castle
walls we can see Arya Stark getting
chased in the trailer HBO also released
a very ominous teaser trailer where we
can see Jon Arya and Sansa down in the
crypts of Winterfell as the night Kings
cold air comes creeping into their
cavernous vault we also cannot forget
about Cersei and Euron
the Starks will also have to try to
defeat them as well so although it was
very nice to see all the Starks together
again there is a very good chance this
family could get ripped apart in a
literal sense now obviously I don't want
that to happen but we do have to be
realistic let's go over each member from
how stark then you can give me your
prediction at the end of the video now
I'm sure there are some fans who believe
all the Starks will survive this show
but I happen to think we can see at
least one more of them die before
everything comes to an end when Game of
Thrones first started House Stark was
one of the biggest fan
in the show but over the years we have
lost so many of these beloved characters
now this house is almost on the verge of
extinction if one of them doesn't
produce an heir very soon we also know
there will be a final shocking event we
have been told that there would be three
and so far the first to both resulted in
a death as of right now I would say
there are four remaining members from
House Stark
we have Arya Stark Sean's a Stark bran
Stark and John Snow now we all know
Johnson knows realize name as Targaryen
but he will always be a stark in my eyes
like I said earlier all four of these
characters are now together in
Winterfell preparing for an attack from
the night King now let's go over some of
the reasons why I think we could lose
another member of House Stark let's go
ahead and get Jon Snow out of the way
first because I assume he will be the
one leading most of the other characters
into battle based on that alone Jon
probably has the highest chance of
getting killed again I can almost
guarantee we will see Jon go
head-to-head against the night king and
that will not be an easy task I guess
you could say this about all the Starks
because at one time or another
each of them did have a price on their
head but Jon has nearly died in every
single season thus far we see Jon Snow
put himself in danger time and time
again because he's not afraid to lead
the charge during an attack we saw this
during the battle for Castle black when
Jon Snow rode the elevator down to
defend the castle against the wildlings
even in the very next episode he almost
got himself killed when he decided to go
out and greet Mance Rayder alone without
taking his sword Longclaw we saw Jon
Snow come very close to getting killed
during the battle at hardhome
he went toe-to-toe against a white
Walker and he nearly paid the ultimate
price but long Clause saved him just in
the nick of time then again in the next
season we saw him risk his own life to
try to save Rick Owens during the Battle
of the bastards
even as recently as last season John
volunteered to go in an extremely
dangerous mission to capture a white it
was basically a suicide mission but
thanks to Danny in his uncle Benjen he
was able to make it out of there alive
now that we are heading into the last
season could Jon Snow's time be running
out how many times can he narrowly
escaped death like this so far Jon has
come face-to-face with the night king
two times they had two very intense
stare downs during those moments
this season we will finally see this
payoff when they have their final
confrontation now I do happen to think
Jon Snow will beat the night king but
that doesn't mean John walks away from
this fight either not only is the night
king and his army extremely dangerous
but I have also suspected he has other
tricks up his sleeve we also know John
is not afraid to die
in fact he told Melisandre just before
the Battle of the bastards if I die
again don't bring me back
we will without a doubt see Jon Snow
thrust right into the heart of all these
battles this season also in the most
recent teaser HBO released last week we
could see Jon Snow's sword covered in
blood and laying in the snow we did not
see Jon Snow's body which something
could mean that he was resurrected by
the night King how many of you think Jon
Snow is actually marked for death in the
final season now let's move on to Arya
Stark
besides Jon Snow's she is pretty much
the only other stark I can picture
fighting in all the upcoming battles of
this season Arya has been training for
this day ever since the first season of
the show not only was she trained by the
great Syrio Forel but she also got some
very special training from the one and
only Jack and agar we have seen Arya
Stark kill many different characters
over the years but we have yet to see
her fight in any battles while all of
that is about to change very soon based
on what we saw in the first official
trailer it looks like Arya could die
next season it's not often that we see
Arya gets scared but she appears to be
terrified when we see her getting chased
through her own castle if the knight
king's army has made it that far inside
of the Starks home you have to wonder
how many of them will make it out of
there alive Arya Stark sword needle
which Jon gave to her back in season one
was also featured in that aftermath
teaser we can see her sword sticking
into the ground without any sign of Arya
Stark now as much as I think that was
made to simply hype up the last season I
would be lying to you if I said it
doesn't concern me at least a little bit
the image of Arya sword in the snow
reminds me of a quote from the very
first book a game of Thrones Jon says
something to Arya that always made me
think it could be foreshadowing her own
death John said Arya when the spring
thaw comes they will find your body with
a needle still locked tight between your
frozen fingers this was the very first
thing I
when I saw needle sticking into the
ground like that in the aftermath teaser
now I love me some Arya Stark just as
much as the next person but is she
destined to die before the show comes to
an end Arya has always been so closely
connected to her aunt Lyanna Stark
not only does she act like her but she
is also said to resemble her it also
makes me wonder if she will meet the
same tragic fate of dying young now
let's move on to our sister songs of
stark now this is a character I do not
imagine will be fighting in any other
battles don't get me wrong I would love
to see songs that grab a sword and swing
it but I just don't think that happens
she is more or less the lady of
Winterfell and I think everyone will do
everything in their power to keep her
safe songs also has her own personal
bodyguard in brain at ARF so when you
consider that along with the fact that
she might not fight in the battles she
might have the best chance of surviving
out of the rest of her siblings however
that could also be her downfall her not
knowing how to defend herself could also
get her killed
especially when their Castle gets over
ran by the night king's army what good
songs actually do if she gets trapped
and surrounded by White's there is also
something else from one of the teasers
we cannot ignore like I said before we
know Winterfell gets over ran by White's
Arya is shown getting chased through the
castle their only means of escape may be
through the hidden tunnels down in the
crypts of Winterfell not too long ago
HBO uploaded a teaser that shows Jon
Shawn's ax and Arya down here in the
crypts of Winterfell right as the night
King seems to be entering that same
location that could symbolize exactly
what happens this season the night king
and his army may force them to hide down
there and he might even trap them down
there now one of the other things we saw
was John Sansa and Arya is very own
statues what does that actually say
about the fates of these characters are
all three of them destined to die this
season I think this is at least what HBO
wants us to believe whether it's true or
not now the interesting thing about this
is we did not see Bryan Starks statue
down there what does that have to say
about the fate of Bryan Stark he is
actually the character I am most
concerned about bran hasn't been able to
train to fight since he was very young
but worst of all he's in a wheelchair
he won't even be able to run if the army
makes it inside the castle the thing
puts bran in the most danger as the
night king himself we recently found out
that the night king does have a specific
target and I believe that target is
Brandon Stark
we know he has been actively seeking out
bran ever since they met face to face
inside of the weirwood net he was able
to leave a mark on brains arm at that
time and that allowed him to attack and
enter the cave that bran was hiding in
ever since then the night King has been
hot on his trail the night King started
to bring his entire army south right
after brain Amira got away even as
recently as last season we saw just how
deep brain and the night Kings
connection goes bran sent his drones out
to spy on the night Kings movements but
the night King immediately sensed that
bran was there and he forced him right
out of those birds I've always said that
we will get one more big reveal about
the night king and that might tie into
some of the theories surrounding his
connection to House Stark some fans
believe bran Stark at the night King are
the same character and if Jon kills
Lanai King then it would almost
simultaneously kill bran Stark there are
even theories that say brand will have
to enter the mind of the night king to
try to slow him down enough for someone
to kill him but that could also kill
bran Stark in the process either way the
night Kings death and brain Starks death
may have to be intertwined in some way
you also have to wonder what would
happen if I rain Stark if all the magic
started to fade away as of right now it
seems like bran in the night King are
both getting their powers from the same
source which is the children of the
forest and the weirwood trees now in
order to stop the night king you might
have to destroy that power source by
cutting down or burning all the weirwood
trees the only problem is that could
kill bran Stark as well now as I said
before we did not see bran stark statue
down in the crypts of Winterfell besides
John Aria and Songz's but we did however
see bran Starks chair broken at the
bottom of the steps in that aftermath
trailer
based on that image alone things do not
look good for bran stark but then again
who really knows only one thing is for
sure
Winterfell will be under attack and how
stark will burn the question is who
lives and who dies
how many characters from House Stark if
any do you think will die let me know
what you think down below hopefully I'll
see all of you again in just a few hours
when I upload my breakdown video for the
first episode of the
season make sure you subscribe that way
you can see any and every video I
release this season trust me I will be
uploading a lot of videos during this
six weeks anyways I want to thank you
all for watching and supporting the
channel I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you